Hi there. This is Will Arnett, host of the Will Arnett FunZone podcast.
This week, what?
We've talked about this, man. We've been over this like so many times.
Okay. But we are doing it though, right? We are going to do that.
No, we're not. This is Smartless.
Okay. FunZone.
I know. Well, what are we doing today?
All we need is a super simple, welcome to Smartless.
大家好。我是威尔·阿奈特，威尔·阿奈特FunZone播客的主持人。这周，什么？我们谈过这个了，伙计。我们已经讨论过很多次了。好吧。但我们确实要这么做，对吧？我们要去做那个。不，我们不去做。这是Smartless。好吧。FunZone。我知道。好吧，我们今天要做什么？我们只需要一个超级简单的，欢迎来到Smartless。
Oh, right.
You're a dig deep for this.
Welcome to Smartless.
Now listen, Jason, before we get too deep into the show,
we need to talk about the crew caller.
And now you've, tell us what, walk us through what happened this morning.
Well, I went ahead and I got showered and changed prior to our record
for my golf engagement following this record.
哦，对了。你得深入挖掘一下。欢迎来到Smartless。现在听着，杰森，在我们深入节目之前，我们需要谈谈工作人员的电话。现在你，告诉我们，给我们讲讲今天早上发生了什么。嗯，我在录制之前去洗了个澡，换了衣服，因为录制结束后我还要去打高尔夫球。
Oh, you go.
Yeah, I'm not proud to say, but chuckles over there does it too.
So, yeah, so I put on my collared shirt as you're required to do.
And then it's a little chilly here in Los Angeles.
So I put on a nice wrap over the top of it, a nice cashmere wrap.
And the collar on that creaneck was a little tight.
So it took the collar of my undershirt there and pushed it up.
And then Will was hurting me, calling it a mock turtorn.
哦，你去吧。是的，我不以此为荣，但那边的那个傻笑的家伙也这么做。所以，是的，我穿上了你必须穿的带领衬衫。然后洛杉矶这里有点冷。所以我外面加了一件漂亮的罩衫，一件漂亮的羊绒罩衫。那件圆领衫的领口有点紧。所以它把我的内衣领子往上推了。然后威尔就在嘲笑我，叫它假高领。
So that sweater's gone.
I'm going to go to a V-neck.
And Will said we were talking about money for producing the podcast.
And Will said.
What's the budget for mock turtlenecks for Jason for the budget?
I don't come here under the budget.
I've already maxed it.
It's a fair question.
所以那件毛衣没了。我要换成V领的。威尔说我们在谈论制作播客的预算。威尔说。杰森的假高领毛衣预算是多少？我来这里不是为了预算。我已经把它用光了。这是一个公平的问题。
First of all, you're allowed to mock a mock turtle neck.
It's built into the name.
Name.
Okay.
But by the way, you'll never see me in a mock turtleneck.
You'll never see me in a turtleneck for sure because I've got probably, you know,
they ask you sometimes, you know, what's the one thing you change about your body?
It's probably my non-superhero jawline.
首先，你可以嘲笑假高领。它名字里就带着呢。名字。好吧。但顺便说一句，你永远不会看到我穿假高领。你肯定永远不会看到我穿高领，因为我可能，你知道，人们有时会问你，你知道，你对自己身体最想改变的一点是什么？可能是我那不够超级英雄的下颌线。
I've got sort of like a
sort of a diagonal
a diagonal from the end of my chin
to my Adam's apple as opposed to a 90 degree thing
so if I wear a turtleneck
I then have the turkey goblet
hangover over the edge
that cascades, that skin
我的下巴到喉结之间有一条斜线，而不是90度的线条，所以如果我穿高领衫，我的火鸡脖子就会挂在边缘，那层皮肤
that cascades over the edge of the turtle
I can't have it
I disagree you both have nice
silhouettes
go back to the thing though
about being cold it's cold in L.A
I came down the stairs today I'm not
not making this up I came downstairs
那层皮肤会垂在高领边缘，我受不了。我不同意，你们俩的轮廓都很好。回到刚才说的冷的话题，洛杉矶确实很冷。我今天下楼的时候，我不是在编故事，我下楼的时候
And Scotty had the heat on, on the first floor of Los Angeles,
and the heat.
And I was sweating by the time I got to the bottom of it.
Sean, you come down the stairs, your Hollywood house.
Every day like Gloria Swanson, right?
That's right.
In a flowing house coat.
Yeah.
斯科蒂在洛杉矶的一楼开了暖气，暖气。我走到楼下时已经在出汗了。肖恩，你走下楼梯，你的好莱坞房子。每天都像格洛丽亚·斯旺森一样，对吧？没错。穿着飘逸的家居长袍。是的。
Ready for my close-up.
It's so great to see you guys.
It's so great to see you guys, too.
This is really exciting.
I'm excited for you guys to talk to our guest today.
Oh, I am excited to listen.
Because our guest is somebody, this is a mega talent.
This person is a person who's been doing it for a long time.
准备好我的特写镜头了。见到你们真是太好了。见到你们也太好了。这真的很令人兴奋。我很兴奋你们能和我们今天的嘉宾交谈。哦，我很兴奋能听。因为我们的嘉宾是某个人，这是一个超级天才。这个人是一个已经在这个行业做了很长时间的人。
This person is not just an actor.
This person is a writer.
This person is a skilled musician who started playing violin at the age of three.
They can play the piano, accordion, trombone, guitar, harmonica,
and has written and improvised music a lot in a show that they've done now for many, many years.
This person received an honorary done.
doctorate from performing arts from Merrimack College.
This person, you know, was active at Williamstown Theater Festival back in the day.
这个人不仅仅是一个演员。这个人是一位作家。这个人是一位熟练的音乐家，三岁就开始拉小提琴。他们会弹钢琴、手风琴、长号、吉他、口琴，并且在他们现在做了很多很多年的节目中写过很多即兴音乐。这个人获得了梅里马克学院颁发的表演艺术荣誉博士学位。这个人，你知道，过去在威廉斯敦戏剧节很活跃。
This person has gone onto a huge career in television in, I guess, the longest-running TV
comedy of all time.
This person has to be slow down here.
I want to do some guesses here.
Well, this is my guess, and it makes sense because this is my friend, and I'm so happy
to have my friend, and I want you guys to start trying to guess.
This person has done lots of movies.
This person was in the Lego movie with me.
这个人后来在电视界拥有了巨大的职业生涯，我想，是有史以来播出时间最长的电视喜剧。这个人必须在这里慢下来。我想在这里做一些猜测。好吧，这是我的猜测，这很有道理，因为这是我的朋友，我很高兴有我的朋友，我希望你们开始尝试猜测。这个人拍过很多电影。这个人曾和我一起出演《乐高大电影》。
This is Charlie Day?
The longest running comedy.
The Lego movie, too.
Yeah.
Pacific Rim.
Horrible bosses and its sequel.
Well, it's got to be Chuck Day.
Yeah, it's Chuck Day.
这是查理·戴吗？播出时间最长的喜剧。《乐高大电影》也是。是的。《环太平洋》。《恶老板》及其续集。好吧，那一定是查理·戴。是的，是查理·戴。
Oh, my God.
All right.
You're scraping the bottom of the barrel,
Matt, boy.
No, I was...
Time to wrap the show up.
So, Chuck,
what about...
哦，天哪。好吧。你在刮桶底了，马特小子。不，我当时……是时候结束节目了。所以，查理，关于……
This is, now, I think the reason you've taken so long to book on this is your schedule.
It took a real long time for someone to ask me.
I can't believe Rob McElhaney beat you onto this show.
What does that say about us?
Here's my favorite part, is that Bateman and Chuck Day have been friends for many years.
They've done a few movies together, and I was so happy to steal Charlie as my guest from under Bateman.
Just a really point.
I would have had him on, too.
这是，现在，我想你花这么长时间才预订这个节目是因为你的日程安排。花了好长时间才有人邀请我。我不敢相信罗布·麦克尔亨尼比你先上这个节目。这说明了我们什么？我最喜欢的部分是，贝特曼和查理·戴已经做了很多年的朋友了。他们一起拍过几部电影，我很高兴能从贝特曼手下抢走查理作为我的嘉宾。真的。我也本该邀请他的。
I know.
I think maybe you did ask me.
Yeah, definitely.
And then you were saying, yeah, gosh, you know, I don't know.
We're starting a podcast.
And I think he gave me a little bit of a runaround.
And I don't like to pressure people.
I know you were looking to get paid quite a bit of money for today's spot.
我知道。我想也许你确实问过我。是的，肯定。然后你说，哎呀，你知道，我不知道。我们正在创办一个播客。我想他给了我一点推脱。我不喜欢给别人压力。我知道你今天想为这个名额赚不少钱。
I was waiting for you guys to make money so I could start make money, which is cool.
Because Will cut me a great check for this.
I had to send him over cash, a guy with a rucksack full of cash.
Yeah.
And that's a pay cut for me, guys.
Because you're not doing that well, right?
You know, that show is not paying you.
I've made a lot of bad decisions, though.
我一直在等你们赚钱，这样我就可以开始赚钱了，这很酷。因为威尔为这个给我开了一张很棒的支票。我不得不派人给他送去现金，一个背着装满现金的背包的家伙。是的。这对我是减薪，伙计们。因为你们做得不是很好，对吧？你知道，那个节目没给你钱。不过我确实做了很多糟糕的决定。
You know what I mean?
I made a lot of sketchy calls.
Wait, we had, Charlie, we had McElhaney on it.
And is it really the longest running sitcom in history?
Yeah.
Yeah, well, years.
If you don't count episodes, I think you did more episodes of Will and Grace in like two seasons.
And then we've done, but.
你知道我的意思吗？我做过很多草率的决定。等等，我们有，查理，我们有麦克尔亨尼在上面。这真的是历史上播出时间最长的情景喜剧吗？是的。是的，嗯，多年了。如果你不算集数，我想你在两季里拍的《威尔和格蕾丝》比我们拍的还多。但是。
How many years is it now?
This is something we don't want to gloss over because this is, this is, you should be,
and I'm sure you are, so proud of how long this show has been on the air.
Yeah, it's so cool.
This doesn't just make itself.
We're talking, of course, about all of a sudden in Philadelphia.
I had 15 years.
Jesus.
现在是多少年了？这是我们不想掩盖的事情，因为这是，这是，你应该，我相信你也是，为这个节目播出这么久感到自豪。是的，太酷了。这不是自己拍出来的。我们当然是在谈论《费城永远阳光灿烂》。我有15年了。天哪。
We just have a 15th season.
15 years.
And you're about to do another one or two?
I don't know, at least another one.
And we'll see after that.
Look at the way he's positioning right there.
I know.
He knows Fox is listening.
我们刚刚有了第15季。15年。你还要再拍一两季吗？我不知道，至少再拍一季。之后再看吧。看看他现在的定位方式。我知道。他知道福克斯在听。
Of course.
Or whatever the hell it is.
And he's going to jam him again.
He's going to get it to 20.
You know what it is.
We've done a lot.
We've done a lot of these.
I don't know how long we can keep them off.
当然。或者不管那是什么鬼东西。他又要卡住他们了。他会把它弄到20季。你知道那是什么。我们做了很多。我们做了很多这样的节目。我不知道我们还能把他们挡在外面多久。
Nothing adds more zeros than a foot out the door, right?
I mean, that's just gets them.
That's true, yeah.
So, Charlie, let's talk a little bit about it,
because we're talking about all of a Sunday in Philadelphia,
which is a huge, long-running show, longest by years.
Could you have imagined, take us back to the day
when you actually, when it actually became a TV show?
没有什么比一只脚跨出门外更能增加零了，对吧？我的意思是，那确实能让他们……这是真的，是的。所以，查理，让我们谈谈它，因为我们正在谈论《费城永远阳光灿烂》，这是一个巨大的、长期播出的节目，按年数算最长。你能想象吗，带我们回到它真正成为电视节目的那天？
Because we had Rob on here when we talked about it.
You guys made some videos and stuff and you shot some stuff.
Am I remembering that correctly, and you took it to FX?
Yeah, that's basically it.
I mean, we were shooting in my apartment,
which was on the corner of Western and Franklin there.
I lived...
And I think I paid $600 a month for rent.
因为我们之前邀请罗布来这里谈过这件事。你们拍了一些视频之类的东西，你们拍了一些东西。我记得没错吧，你们把它带到了FX？是的，基本就是这样。我的意思是，我们在我的公寓里拍摄，就在西大街和富兰克林街的拐角处。我住……我想我每个月付600美元的房租。
You got Rob.
Quick aside, Jason, last time you were east of Coenga,
five, four, three, three, two,
back in the drug days, for sure.
Yeah, I think I might have seen you scoring on the corner.
There was a pay phone I'd like to hang out out.
Yeah, I'd have to run you down a dime bag or something.
I was still there.
你抓住了罗布。快速插一句，杰森，你上次去科恩加东边，五，四，三，三，二，在毒品日子里，肯定。是的，我想我可能在拐角处看到你交易。有一个公用电话，我喜欢在那儿待着。是的，我得给你弄点小袋子什么的。我还在那儿。
I'm sure what it was.
Oh, my God.
So you're in your apartment.
Right, and was there a phone call from your agent or manager or something that said,
they bought it?
You know what it was?
So we had shot this thing and it was like pretty good, but we knew we'd sort of not hit the nail on the head.
And we had nothing really going on.
我确定那是什么。哦，天哪。所以你在你的公寓里。对，有没有来自你的经纪人或经理之类的电话说，他们买了它？你知道那是什么吗？所以我们拍了这个东西，它还挺不错的，但我们知道我们有点没切中要害。而且我们真的没什么进展。
So we redid the whole thing.
We were doing it so cheaply.
We were holding the cameras.
We had a little boom.
It was real low rent.
And our second goal,
around was pretty funny. We thought, are there something here? And we were all at three arts
management at the time. So like Nick Frankel and Michael Rotenberg took it to WME, and they kind of sat on it
所以我们重做了整个事情。我们拍得太便宜了。我们拿着摄像机。我们有一个小吊杆。这真的很低端。我们的第二次尝试相当有趣。我们想，这里面有什么东西吗？当时我们都在三艺管理公司。所以尼克·弗兰克尔和迈克尔·罗滕伯格把它带到了WME，他们有点把它搁置了
for a while. They're like, yeah, maybe we'll hook you up with a big producer. And we waited forever for
John Favreau to watch it. And he just, I guess he never got around to it.
The one that got away. I know. Well, I mean, I'm so glad I'm not cutting half a check to
John, you know, like, I mean, I'm sure he would have helped a lot, but, you know, it's nice not to have to be paying him anything.
But eventually, we got kind of bored, and we shot a third episode.
Literally, you shot it because you were just in this waiting because the agencies are so you're just, you guys are on their timetable.
Well, that, and the only thing to do on Western is either move the dime bags or shoot another episode.
And it should be, it should be noted, can I just take this?
一段时间。他们说，是的，也许我们会给你找个大制片人。我们等了乔恩·费儒很久才看它。我想他一直没空看。那个溜走的机会。我知道。好吧，我的意思是，我很高兴我不用给乔恩分一半的支票，你知道，我的意思是，我相信他肯定帮了很多忙，但是，你知道，不用付给他任何钱感觉很好。但最终，我们有点无聊了，我们拍了第三集。真的，你们拍它是为了等待，因为代理机构是，所以你们只是，你们是在他们的时间表上。好吧，那个，而且在西大街唯一能做的事要么是卖小袋子，要么是拍另一集。而且应该，应该指出，我可以插一句吗？
Am I right in saying this?
and you guys can agree or disagree with me.
The agenting in show business is hilarious because, like,
you can't get in touch with your agent in the first thing in the morning
because they're in a staff meeting.
Every agent takes lunch at one o'clock no matter what,
so they're out of the office for two hours.
But they need an hour or so to get there, so they leave at 12.
我说得对吗？你们可以同意或不同意我的观点。演艺界的代理工作太搞笑了，因为，就像，你早上第一件事就联系不上你的经纪人，因为他们在开员工会议。每个经纪人不管怎样都在一点钟吃午饭，所以他们离开办公室两个小时。但他们需要一个小时左右才能到那里，所以他们在12点就走了。
Sorry, we lost him.
He's on his way to a lunch.
And then he's back at three.
Then they do the thing as like, well, he's not in the office.
Why not?
Well, because next week is Thanksgiving.
Yeah, next week is Thanksgiving.
Not this week.
抱歉，我们失去他了。他在去吃午饭的路上。然后他三点回来。然后他们做那种事，就像，嗯，他不在办公室。为什么不呢？嗯，因为下周是感恩节。是的，下周是感恩节。不是这周。
The fuck are you doing it?
And then the month of December.
And then the month of December, sorry, it's the holidays, sure, got it, and then they go.
And then, you know, obviously, Sundance is at the end of January.
So nobody's back till Feb 1.
It's the most ridiculous racket of all time.
We were getting a lot of it.
Yeah.
你到底在干什么？然后是十二月。然后是十二月，抱歉，是假期，当然，明白了，然后他们就走了。然后，你知道，显然，圣丹斯电影节在一月底。所以没人回来直到2月1日。这是有史以来最荒谬的敲诈。我们当时遇到了很多这种情况。是的。
The end of the day goes like this, well, the end of the day goes, sorry, we're closed.
He's going to start rolling calls, and then they call knowing you're not going to pick up.
Yeah, or they call you at 7 o'clock, and you're having dinner with the kid,
And you're like, why are you calling me now?
Right.
Sorry.
Sorry, Charley.
No, that's it, though.
一天结束时是这样的，嗯，一天结束时是，抱歉，我们下班了。他要开始轮流打电话了，然后他们打电话时知道你不会接。是的，或者他们在7点钟给你打电话，你正在和孩子吃晚饭，然后你会想，你为什么现在给我打电话？对。抱歉。抱歉，查理。不，就是这样。
We lost sort of patience with that kind of thing.
And we said, we're going to leave you guys and we're going to go to a different agency with this.
And that sort of prompted them setting a bunch of meetings.
And Rob went around because we thought maybe it would be too much to have all three of us in the meeting.
So Rob went.
And we had an offer from FX to shoot a, you know, a real pilot with a real budget.
Rob's the closer.
He's a closer.
我们对那种事情失去了耐心。我们说，我们要离开你们，我们要带着这个去另一家代理机构。这促使他们安排了一堆会议。罗布去了，因为我们认为让三个人都参加会议可能太多了。所以罗布去了。我们收到了FX的提议，让我们拍一个，你知道，真正的试播集，有真正的预算。罗布是终结者。他是个终结者。
He's better in the meeting.
he's a better salesman.
Now, how are you in meetings?
Because I don't think I'm great in meetings.
I don't enjoy them.
I feel like I'm trapped in an office.
I feel like I'm 45 minutes from getting out of these walls,
so it better not go bad in the next minute or two because I'm stuck.
他在会议上表现更好。他是个更好的推销员。那么，你在会议上表现如何？因为我觉得我在会议上表现不好。我不喜欢它们。我觉得我被困在办公室里了。我觉得我离走出这些墙还有45分钟，所以最好在接下来的一两分钟内不要出问题，因为我被困住了。
Like all those things I start to feel, I start to think about,
and then just the walls start getting closer and closer like Star Wars.
How are you?
Do you look at it as like an arena?
Like, I'm on stage or this is fun, like let's win.
or are you looking to get out of there?
It's tough.
It's a tough part of this business.
就像所有那些我开始感觉到的事情，我开始思考，然后墙壁开始像《星球大战》一样越来越近。你怎么样？你把它看作是一个竞技场吗？就像，我在舞台上或者这很有趣，让我们赢吧。还是你想离开那里？这很难。这是这个行业中艰难的一部分。
You know, it depends.
They're all very different.
You go into a meeting and you just,
sometimes you just get cold stairs.
Yeah.
Well, often.
I do have that vibe sometimes of like,
well, here's the idea, guys.
你知道，这取决于情况。它们都非常不同。你走进一个会议，你只是，有时你只会得到冷眼。是的。嗯，经常。我有时确实有那种感觉，嗯，这是个主意，伙计们。
Do you want to buy it or not?
Okay.
If you have that indifference, what's it called, Will?
It's called sexy.
It's called sexy indifference.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Charlie, you know about his sexy indifference, right?
Yeah.
你们想买还是不想买？好吧。如果你有那种冷漠，那叫什么，威尔？这叫性感。这叫性感冷漠。是的，是的，是的。查理，你知道他的性感冷漠，对吧？是的。
It's one of it.
I'm still working on it.
The major terms.
But yeah, you know, it's, you're either selling or you're buying.
The buyers usually look at you with absolutely no expression because they can.
The sellers, us, have to go in there like, you know, circus clowns because we're selling.
And that's really what we do in this business.
And in a good year, you're selling, you know, you're selling yourself six, seven, eight times and winning.
这是其中之一。我还在努力。主要条款。但是的，你知道，这是，你要么在卖，要么在买。买家通常看着你没有任何表情，因为他们可以。卖家，我们，必须像，你知道，马戏团小丑一样走进去，因为我们在卖。这确实是我们在这个行业中所做的。在好的一年里，你在卖，你知道，你在卖你自己六、七、八次并获胜。
Like, in other words, you get fired, you know, half a dozen times.
rehired half a dozen times if you're killing it. So, I mean, how many people in other industries
have to sell themselves or get fired or rehired maybe three, four times over their whole life?
I mean, we've got to do that all the time. It's tough. It was hard for me. It is crazy,
but then you look at the flip of it, Charlie. So you guys, you guys go through this process.
You make this thing, you wait, you make this thing, you wait, you're waiting, you have to
threaten to leave the agency. Finally, FX buys it. You guys are kind of a little bit hat in hand.
And now all these years later, you're at the position we asked you're at, like, are you going to do more?
换句话说，你被解雇了，你知道，半打次。如果你表现出色，会被重新雇佣半打次。所以，我的意思是，其他行业有多少人必须推销自己或被解雇或重新雇佣三、四次在他们的一生中？我的意思是，我们必须一直这样做。这很难。这对我来说很难。这很疯狂，但当你看到它的另一面时，查理。所以你们，你们经历了整个过程。你们做这个东西，你们等，你们做这个东西，你们等，你们在等，你们不得不威胁要离开代理机构。最终，FX买了它。你们有点手心向上。现在这么多年过去了，你们处于我们问你们所处的位置，就像，你们还要做更多吗？
Maybe I'll do one more, whatever.
Like, you have, the tables have turned a little bit.
Yeah, well.
Not a little bit, a lot.
Yeah, I mean, I think the thing is, though, when we were shooting that pilot, I was 27 years old.
Right.
And I'm 46, and so I feel like, you know, I put in my time with this one.
You look 23, though.
也许我会再做一个，什么的。就像，你已经，局面有点扭转了。是的，嗯。不是一点点，是很多。是的，我的意思是，我认为事情是这样的，当我们拍摄那个试播集时，我27岁。对。我46岁了，所以我感觉，你知道，我在这上面花了很多时间。不过你看上去23岁。
I know it's incredible.
I know. It's incredible.
Yeah. Must be a real stress-free set there.
But we all make stuff
we all produce or write or direct or act whatever
And Charlie kind of what Jason was talking about
Is there a point where you
Like are you getting to a point
我知道这太不可思议了。我知道。这太不可思议了。是的。那里的片场一定压力很小。但我们都制作东西，我们都制作或写作或导演或表演什么的，查理，就像杰森刚才说的，有没有一个点，你，就像，你是否到了一个点
Where it's bothersome that the grind is getting to you
About getting all these nose?
Because it seems now to put together a package
To sell something you have to really stack the deck high
Before anybody will even consider
You hear about Merrill Streep getting past or on
Or whoever these big stars
Go out to pitch these shows
当这种磨练让你感到困扰时，关于得到所有这些拒绝？因为现在看起来要组装一个包裹来卖东西，你必须真正把筹码堆得很高，在任何人考虑之前。你听说梅丽尔·斯特里普被拒绝，或者无论这些大明星是谁，出去推销这些节目
and they get past, well, if they get past
and I'm stacking these deck and we're getting
those, what does it take to keep a production
company going? I like to
get everything done independently
of a partner. So, you know,
like, I'd rather, if I'm
going to be pitching a movie, I'd rather have the whole thing
然后他们被拒绝，好吧，如果他们被拒绝，而我正在堆叠这些筹码，我们却得到了拒绝，维持一家制作公司需要什么？我喜欢独立于合作伙伴完成所有事情。所以，你知道，比如，如果我要推销一部电影，我宁愿把整个事情
written. Right. And say, you know,
and a director in place, and an actor
in place. Yeah. Yeah. We're going.
This is what it is. So all they do is write the check.
Basically. Yeah. Yeah.
You know, as it should be.
Yeah, but then that means you got to do a bunch of work for
free ahead of time, which is cool if you've got the time and the funds to bank on yourself
写好。对。并说，你知道，并且有一个导演到位，一个演员到位。是的。是的。我们要走了。这就是它。所以他们所要做的就是写支票。基本上。是的。是的。你知道，理应如此。是的，但这意味着你必须提前做很多免费工作，如果你有时间和资金来押注自己，这很酷
and work for free for a little while.
Look, at some point, you're going to have to do that work anyway.
So I'm usually, it depends, right?
There's other things I'll pitch and I'll know, okay, I want to get a writer on this
and I want to get that person paid.
But even then, I'll work with that writer.
I'll develop a whole outline.
So that movie is basically ready to go.
并免费工作一段时间。看，在某些时候，你无论如何都得做那项工作。所以我通常，这取决于情况，对吧？还有其他事情我会推销，我会知道，好吧，我想找个编剧来做这个，我想让那个人得到报酬。但即使那样，我也会和那个编剧合作。我会制定一个完整的大纲。所以那部电影基本上准备好了。
and I'll attach a few people to the movie
and then I'll go and it be like,
here it is, this is what it is,
here's who's acting in it, here's the director,
now please pay this guy right.
And Will and Sean, you've got to understand.
This guy is, he's so fast and he's so good.
He wrote horrible bosses too
我会给电影附加几个人，然后我会去，就像，这就是它，这就是它，这是谁在演，这是导演，现在请付给这家伙报酬。威尔和肖恩，你们必须明白。这家伙，他太快了，他太棒了。他也写了《恶老板》
on a five-hour plane ride from New York to Los Angeles.
I'm not exaggerating.
He did a complete rewrite, page one rewrite on it,
and we used most of it.
Wow.
Out of deference to our writers that wrote the draft
before. I'm exaggerating a little bit, but Charlie deserves a great deal of credit for that.
Well, I appreciate that. I don't want to take credit away from, you know, the guys who wound
在从纽约到洛杉矶的五小时飞机航程中。我没有夸张。他做了一个完整的重写，第一页重写，我们用了大部分。哇。出于对之前写草稿的编剧的尊重。我稍微夸张了一点，但查理应该为此获得很大的功劳。好吧，我很感激。我不想抢走，你知道，那些最终完成它们的人的功劳。你甚至不记得名字。他很快，但他是个评论家。我写得很快。我对名字真的很慢。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。等等，说到名字，所以你和显然你和罗布·麦克尔亨尼有长期的关系。你们是怎么认识的？那是什么？我在飞机上遇到了罗布。
up doing them.
You don't even remember the names. He's fast, but he is a critic. I'm fast with writing. I'm
real slow with names. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
Wait, so speaking of names, so you and obviously you have a long-time relationship with
Rob McLean.
How did you guys first meet?
What was that?
I met Rob on a plane.
所以我们都被飞出去。我们都被飞出去测试同一个角色的试播集。那是那种事情之一，你知道，你在机场，你会想，哦，这家伙一定是个演员。你知道，他有那种样子。节目叫《马瑟之家》。它是关于大学生的或者类似的东西。而且，你知道，我想，我不知道我什么时候打的招呼，但也许在飞机降落后。
So we were both being flown out.
We were both being flown out to test for a pilot for the same role.
And it was one of those things where, you know, you're in the airport and you're like,
oh, this guy's got to be an actor.
You know, he's got that look.
And the show is called Matherhouse.
It was about college kids or something like that.
And, you know, I think, I don't know when I said hello, but maybe after the plane landed.
你从哪里来？从纽约？从纽约，是的。我们都住在纽约，我们正在飞出去。你知道，他们把你安置在，比如希尔顿酒店或者101公路旁边的什么地方。哦，是的。在环球影城旁边。没门。
Where were you coming from?
From New York?
From New York, yeah.
We both lived in New York and we were flying out.
You know, they put you up on, like the Hilton or something right off the 101 there.
Oh, yeah.
By Universal.
No way.
很多次。所以我们都住在那里，然后。你过去常在标志上找到杰森。是的。我过去常记得试播季我常去那里住，或者住在福克斯旁边的喜来登或洲际酒店，那是托尼·黑尔和我住的地方，为了《发展受阻》的测试。不管怎样，继续。这是我第二次发生这种情况。
Many times.
So we're both staying there and then.
You used to find Jason on the sign.
Yeah.
I used to remember pilot season I used to come out there and stay there or the Sheraton or the Intercontinental over by Fox,
which is where Tony Hale and I stayed for the arrested test.
Anyway, keep going.
It was my second time that happened.
它发生在我身上。我测试了一个叫《怪异》的东西。他们喜欢我演怪异亨利。他们把我飞了出去。然后他们做了一轮，你知道，和制片人的笔记。然后工作室就像，这个节目不会成功。他们取消了整个事情。
It happened to me.
I tested for something called weird.
And they liked me for Weird Henry.
And they flew me out.
And then they did one sort of, you know,
round of notes with the producers.
And then the studio was like, this show's not going to work.
And they can't the whole thing.
然后罗布也发生了同样的事情。罗布和我两个人都去测试了。我记得当时想，啊，我搞定这家伙了。他没有魅力。我不担心他。看看他那张愚蠢的脸。看看他那张笨脸，伙计。他永远不会在演艺界成功。
And then the same thing happened with Rob.
Rob and I both went and tested.
And I remember thinking like, ah, I got this guy.
He doesn't have the charisma.
I'm not worried about him.
Look at his stupid face.
Look at his dumb face, man.
He's never going to make it in show business.
他永远不会和瑞安·雷诺兹拥有一支足球队。是的。算了吧。他太帅了。我当时想，他太像模特了。你知道，你需要一个真实的人。
He'll never own a football team with
Ryan Reynolds.
Yeah.
Forget it.
He was too handsome.
I was like, he's too modely.
You know,
you need someone real.
然后同样的事情发生了。他们在我们还在那里的时候就取消了整个节目。我们只是有点建立了联系并保持了好友关系，你知道，现在我甩不掉他了。你知道，每年我都会想，嗯，也许我们已经做完这个节目了。
And then the same thing happened.
They canned the whole show
while we were out there.
And we just kind of bonded
and stayed buddies and, you know,
now I can't get rid of him.
You know, every year I'm like,
well, maybe we've done it with the show.
他说，来吧，再来一季。我们走吧。然后，所以不仅你甩不掉《费城永远阳光灿烂》，然后你们还创造了《神话任务》，不仅仅是你们两个，还有别人。是的，和梅根·甘茨。
He's like, come on, one more.
Let's go.
And then, so not only can you not get rid of them
always sunny,
then you guys create Mythic Quest
with,
it wasn't just the two of you with somebody else too.
Yeah, with Megan Gans.
梅根·甘茨。是的，当然。是的，不，我甩不掉这家伙。你知道，我上播客。我只是在谈论他。我就像，我听到了。他几乎不谈论我。我一直在谈论这家伙。不，不，他谈论你很多。我们只是不能重复它。哦，好吧。你们也一起创办了一个播客。现在你们有了这个《费城永远阳光灿烂》播客。
Megan Gantz. Yes, of course.
Yeah, no, I can't get rid of this guy.
You know, I go on podcasts. I'm just talking about him.
I'm like, I hear him. He barely talks about me.
I'm talking about this guy constantly.
No, no, he talks about you quite a bit. We just can't repeat it.
Oh, okay.
And you guys started a podcast together too. Now you've got this all with sunny podcasts.
现在我们正在谈论这个节目，人们正在听。但我们不是来宣传那个的。我们不会谈论那个。不，让我们宣传你拥有的一切。好吧。我想我们真的应该，如果我们真的想让这个节目火起来，我们应该只谈论高尔夫。我们走吧。首先，当我们拍摄《恶老板》时，我有点高尔夫狂，我会说，哦，杰森，你知道，我听说你过去常打高尔夫，你说，是的，我不做了。
And now we're talking about the show and people are listening.
But we're not here to plug that. We're not going to talk about that.
No, let's plug all everything you got.
Okay.
I think we should really, if we really want to get this cooking, we should just talk about golf.
Let's go.
First of all, when we were doing horrible bosses, and I'm a bit of a golf nut, I would say, oh,
Jason, you know, I heard you used to golf and you said, yeah, I don't do it anymore.
我当时想，嗯，你应该和我一起去，你知道，也许什么时候，只是，你知道，掸掉旧球杆，打几杆。你现在是我认识的最爱打高尔夫的人。是的。这太不可思议了。不停地。那时，那时我非常有纪律。我不想再和龙共舞了。
I was like, well, you should come out with me, you know, maybe some time and just, you know,
dust off the old sticks and hit a few.
You are the most golfing man I know now.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
Non-stop.
And back then, back then I was very disciplined.
I didn't want to dance with the dragon again.
你知道，我有成瘾问题。是的，是的，是的。你完全沉迷于高尔夫。是的。和龙共舞。是的，不，不，那是那句谚语。然后在新冠期间，你知道，威尔只是给了我一条救生线。他说，听着，伙计，你得远离雷切尔·马多，脱掉你的睡衣，
You know, I've got addiction issues.
Yes, yes, yes.
You are fully addicted to golf.
Yeah.
Dance with the drag.
Yeah, no, no, that's the saying.
And then during COVID, you know, Will just threw me a lifeline.
He said, listen, buddy, you got to step away from Rachel Maddow, take your PJs off,
让我们出去，做点社交距离的事。让我们打高尔夫。两周后，我们在圆石滩。是的。不开玩笑。他直接把它打进了我的手臂。我喜欢它。嗯，我喜欢你这样做。
and let's get out there, do something socially distant.
Let's play golf.
And two weeks later, we were in Pebble Beach.
Yeah.
No joke.
He put it right in my arm.
I love it.
Well, I love that you do it.
我希望你不要放弃它。不，不，我没有。看看我。我穿好了。看看我的衣服，看在上帝的份上。我离发球时间还有半小时。我们会保持简洁，因为我知道你有发球时间。是的，我们走吧。查理，我有一个……肖恩，我知道你的问题会是，嘿，查理，你发球有多远多直？非常，他在发球台上非常稳定。这太不可思议了。这家伙是单差点选手，听众们。任何喜欢高尔夫的人，这家伙，这家伙打球不超过80杆。这太恶心了。他是个天生的运动员。他小时候打了很多棒球。你对我了解最多。
I hope you don't give it up.
No, no, I don't. Look at me. I'm dressed. Look at my outfit, for Christ's sake. I'm a half hour from the tea.
We'll keep it snappy because I know you got a tea time. Yeah, let's go. Charlie, I have a...
Sean, I know your question is going to be, hey, Charlie, how long and straight are you off the tea?
Very, he's very consistent off the tea. It's unbelievable.
This guy's a single-digit handicap listeners. Anybody who's into golf, this guy, this guy doesn't shoot over 80.
It's gross. He's a natural athlete. He played a lot of baseball when he was coming up.
the most you know about me.
这令人惊讶。等等，所以查理，说到成长，所以我提到你在弹钢琴，你演奏所有这些乐器，那是怎么回事？我不知道哪里……
This is surprising.
Wait, so Charlie,
speaking of growing up,
so I mentioned in the thing
that you play piano
and you play all these instruments,
what's up with that?
I don't know where the...
看看肖恩振作起来。肖恩不想谈论发球台有多远，但是，哦，让我们把那个口琴放进他嘴里，嗯？让我们做吧。我可能随手就有。我不知道小提琴是怎么回事。就像，我当时……
Look at Sean perk up.
Sean doesn't want to talk about
a long off the tea,
but, oh, let's get that harmonica in his mouth, huh?
Let's do it.
I probably have one lying around.
I don't know where the violin thing came.
Like, I was...
谢谢。你准备好了吗？是的，任何时候有糟糕的笑话。嘿，肖恩，我们今年要介绍的那个键盘在哪里？是的。我知道，我太懒了，不想把它抬起来进去，因为他们得把所有东西都接上。但等等，查理，你还……你还拉小提琴吗？
Thank you.
You have that ready to go?
Yeah, anytime there's a bad joke.
Hey, where's that keyboard we were going to introduce this year, Sean?
Yeah.
I know, I'm too lazy to lift this up and go in there because they've got to hook it all up.
But wait, Charlie, do you still...
Do you still play violin?
你还演奏这些乐器吗？不，我从来没拉过小提琴。那是其中之一。所以那不是真的。不，我想我拉小提琴大概从三岁到三岁一个月。你知道，我父母当时就像，嗯，这太小了。维基百科非常准确。有没有你擅长的或者你做过的乐器？
Do you still play these instruments?
No, I never played the violin.
That's one of those.
So that was not true.
No, I think I played the violin from like three to three in one month.
You know, where my parents were like, well, this is too young.
Wikipedia is very accurate.
Is there an instrument that you excel at or that you've done?
坚持下去？保持干净。我哪一个都不擅长。但我可以弹一点钢琴和一点吉他。我可以写一首我们在《费城永远阳光灿烂》里放的那种傻歌。但那是你父母，比如，鼓励的吗，比如，你上过钢琴课和吉他课吗？是的。
stick with?
Keep it clean.
I don't excel at any of them.
But I can play a little piano and a little guitar.
I can write like a goofy song that we put on Sunny.
But was that something that your parents, like,
encouraged, like, did you take piano lessons and guitar lessons?
Yes.
我可能上钢琴课直到10岁，然后我换成了长号。我过去常穿一件小运动衫，因为我在学校乐队里，上面写着查理长号。所以那成了我的绰号太久了。你知道长号的问题是如果你把它留在雨里。它会生锈。你知道什么对。
I took piano lessons maybe until I was 10,
and then I switched to the trombone.
I used to have a little sweatshirt because I was in the school band
that said Charlie trombone.
So that became my nickname for too long.
You know the problem with the trombone is if you leave it in the rain.
It gets rusty.
You know what right.
这是真的。如果你把它留在雨里是真的。干净，它是干净的。嗯，你保持它干净。你弄点什么黄铜清洁剂之类的东西。查理，当你写作和制作或导演，或者无论你做什么时，你在做的时候会想到音乐吗，还是事后才想到的？这是我写作方式的重要组成部分。
It's true.
It's true if you leave it in the rain.
Clean it's clean.
Well, you keep it clean.
You get some kind of brass cleaner or something like that.
Charlie, when you write and produce or director,
whatever you do, do you think about music when you're doing it or is it an afterthought?
It's a big part of how I write something.
我只是会听，你知道，一种音乐风格，我就会有一个主意。赶时髦乐队。是的，我会听赶时髦乐队。我会想，我得和贝特曼拍一部电影，他，你知道，你知道，戴眼影和穿风衣？是的。你应该看看我。我有很棒的，很棒的，有技能。
I'll be just listening to, you know, a style of music and I'll have an idea.
The Pesh mode.
Yeah, I'll be listening to Depeche Mode.
I'll be thinking, I've got to do a movie with Bateman where he, you know,
You know, where's eye shadow and trench coats?
Yeah.
You should see me.
I got great got great got got skills.
是的。我确实喜欢赶时髦乐队。等等，查理，我对……了解太少了，所以上面说你出生在纽约，在城里。是的。真实故事？真实故事。因为我父母，我父母都在哥伦比亚大学相遇，他们都在那里攻读音乐学博士学位。等等。
Yeah.
I do love Depeche Mode.
Wait, Charlie, I know so little about, so it says that you were born in New York, in the city.
Yeah.
True story?
True story.
Because my parents, my parents both met at Columbia, where they were both music, getting their doctorate's in musicology.
Wait a second.
等等。踩刹车。哇。所以你父母，所以你有点略过了整个音乐的事情和你自己与我的参与。你父母有哥伦比亚大学的音乐学位？是的。是的。
Pump the brakes.
Wow.
So your parents, so you kind of brush through the whole music thing
and your own involvement with me.
Your parents have degrees in music from Columbia?
Yeah.
我父母非常聪明。聪明，我妹妹也是。她也有音乐学博士学位。发生了什么？这里发生的是，你知道，我是个白痴。我当时想，我得远离这个音乐的东西。所以，你知道，我上长号课，我所有的伙伴都在外面打棒球。
My parents are very smart.
Smart, as is my sister.
She also has her PhD in musicology.
What happened?
What happened here was that, you know, I'm an idiot.
And I was like, I got to get away from this music thing.
So, you know, I'm taking trombone lessons
and all my buddies are outside playing baseball.
我最终，你知道，走开了。走开了，放弃了这一切。但后来当我到了高中或大学高年级时，我拿起了吉他，我当时想，哦，这也许可能很酷，或者是一种认识女孩的方式。然后我又回到了它。但我不想成为，他们没钱。我不想成为一个音乐人。
And I eventually, you know, walk.
walked away from it all and gave it up.
But then when I got to like maybe a senior in high school or college,
I picked up the guitar and I was like,
oh, this is maybe could be cool or a way to meet a girl.
And then I got back into it.
But I didn't want to be, they had no money.
And I didn't want to be a music person.
所以我成了一名演员。所以他们在哥伦比亚大学。他们都在上课，他们都在哥伦比亚大学的音乐项目中。他们相遇，你出生在城里。然后发生了什么？你在那里住了多久？不久。然后我爸爸在罗德岛的一所大学找到了一份工作。
So they became an actor.
So they're at Columbia.
They're both taking, they're both in programs, music programs at Columbia.
They meet, you're born in the city.
And then what happens?
How long did you live there?
Not long.
And then my dad got a job at a college in Rhode Island.
我母亲的家人很久以前就来自罗德岛，很久以前。他们去了就再也没离开。他们还在那里。所以你在罗德岛长大。我在罗德岛长大，是的。是的。演戏是怎么打动你的？是像高中戏剧那样吗？
And my mother's family was from Rhode Island way back, way back.
And they went and never left.
They're still there.
So you grew up in Rhode Island.
I grew up in Rhode Island, yeah.
Yeah.
How did the acting thing hit you?
Was it like a high school drama thing?
这是一个好问题。我的意思是，我在三四年级演过戏，一直很喜欢。然后我想在高中参加学校戏剧，但我有点太紧张了，不敢加入那个团体。我想，啊，我不知道，我不知道。但有了音乐背景，你认为你可以结合戏剧和音乐
That's a good question.
I mean, I did plays like in third and fourth grade
and always enjoyed it.
And then I wanted to do the school plays in high school,
but I was kind of too nervous to join the group.
I thought, ah, I don't, I don't know.
But with the musical background,
what do you think that you can combine the plays and the music
然后做，肖恩，我们称那为什么？有……的剧院。外面有一种基于音乐的剧院。我不太确定。我想还没有一个术语。你会做音乐剧的例子是什么？五，六，七，八。你知道，吧-那-那-那-那-那-那-那。
and do what, Sean, what do we call that?
The theater that's got...
There's a music-based theater out there.
I'm not quite sure.
I don't think there's a term for it yet.
What would be an example of something that you might do on musical theater?
Five, six, seven, eight.
You know, ba-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
你们会有的。我想把那个滑音哨从他们那里拿走。我的意思是。所以查理，所以你高中毕业了，你说，我要去纽约市，我要尝试成为一名职业吉他手或演员。是的，我确实有那个想法。我当时想，嗯，做吗？
You guys are going to have.
I'd like to take that slide whistle away from them.
I mean.
So then Charlie, so then you finish high school and you say,
I'm going to go to New York City
and I'm going to try to become a professional guitar player or actor.
Yes, I did have that thought.
I was like, well, do it?
哪一个？我不知道。我当时想，也许我想写音乐，也许我想演戏。但你知道你的未来不在罗德岛。它可能在曼哈顿。是的。好吧，首先我上了大学，杰森。那是哪里？
Which one?
I didn't know.
I was like, maybe I want to write music or maybe I want to do acting.
But you knew your future wasn't in Rhode Island.
It was probably in Manhattan.
Yeah.
Well, first I went to college, Jason.
Where was that?
等等，等等。什么是大学？是的，那是工作室学校之后的一所学校。自愿附加学校？我不明白。自愿。是的，那是我当时无法计算的部分。那是在华纳地块的哪个拖车里？
Wait, hang on.
What's college?
Yeah, it's a school after the studio school.
Voluntary additional school?
I don't understand it.
Voluntary.
Yeah, that's the part I couldn't compute when I was.
What trailer was that in on the Warner Lot?
是的，一个轮胎瘪了的。这是发生的事情。我去了自愿附加学校，他们有一个戏剧项目，但他们也有一个棒球队。我没进棒球队，我想，好吧，我会去加入戏剧俱乐部。然后我就迷上了。
Yeah, one with a flat tire.
Here's what happened.
I went to the voluntary additional school,
and they had a theater program,
but they also had a baseball team.
And I didn't make the baseball team,
and I thought, well, I'll go join the theater club.
And then I just got hooked.
我当时在演戏，而且似乎……这是学校吗？在纽约？这所学校在马萨诸塞州北部，叫梅里马克学院，如果你有脉搏就能进去，他们让我进去了，我世界上最喜欢的事情是
I was like doing the plays, and it seems to...
Was this school?
in New York? This school was
in northern Massachusetts called Merrimack
College and you could
get in if you had a pulse and
they let me in and
my favorite thing in the world is
交换糟糕的戏剧故事。我告诉过你们轮椅的故事吗？你得走了。我们走吧。我们走吧。让我们把采访拉到一边。等等。不，很快。这是一个恐怖。我是一个
swapping horrible
theater stories. Did I tell you guys about the
wheelchair story?
You got to go. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's just pull the interview over to the side.
Hang on.
No, really quick.
This was a horror. I was a
高中二年级，我负责更换布景，对吧？提升布景的指挥棒。所以中间我们有，我们正在演一幕。所以每一幕之间，我们有，你知道，15、30秒来更换巨大的布景并把它们拉起来。我负责所有那些液压系统。所以舞台监督指着我，她说，走。
sophomore in high school and
And I was in charge of changing the scenery, right?
The batons that would lift the scenery.
So in between we had like, we were doing one act.
So in between each act, we had like, you know, 15, 30 seconds to change the big, huge scenery
and pull them up.
And I was in charge of all those hydraulics.
So the stage manager points to me, she's like, go.
我没意识到旁边挂着一根绳子，不知怎么地钩住了下一场戏中那个人需要的轮椅。这是我从卡通片里看到的一集。不，我发誓，这真的发生了。我把它升起来了。钩子把轮椅拉了起来。所以幕布升起来了，轮椅就在半空中摇晃。
And I didn't realize there was a rope hanging on the side that somehow hooked onto the wheelchair
that the guy needed in the next scene.
This is an episode from a cartoon I saw.
No, I swear to God, this happened.
And I raised it.
and the hook pulled the wheelchair up.
So the curtain goes up
and the wheelchair is just swinging, hanging in midair.
那家伙的第一句台词是，你知道，类似，我不知道我是否还能再走路。但他不得不，这太糟糕了。哦，天哪。回到SmartList。嘿，查理。所以你在那里，所以你从初级学院下来，你来到纽约市
And the guy's first line was, you know,
something like, I don't know if I'll ever walk again.
But he had to, it was awful.
Oh, golly.
Back to SmartList.
Hey, Charlie.
So you're up there, so you come down out of the junior college
and you come to New York City
你不仅仅是敲门说我在这儿，我想成为一名演员。你会在报纸上找试镜或经纪人，还是你的第一步是什么？是的，我做了所有那些垃圾。你知道，你得到乡村之声，你在看所有那些东西。我在大学时运气很好。那里有个叫约翰·福斯曼的家伙，他就像那种35岁还在上大学的家伙。只是在学校外面闲逛。
and you don't just knock.
on a door and say I'm here, I'd like to be an actor.
Do you look in the paper for auditions or an agent or what was your first step?
Yeah, I did all that crap.
You know, you get the village voice and you're looking through all those things.
I had a really lucky break when I was in college.
There was a guy there named John Fusman and he was like one of those guys who was like 35 and in college.
And just hanging out just outside the school grounds.
基本上。是的。是的，他向我透露了一个叫威廉斯敦戏剧节的地方。当然。我去那里，你知道，倒垃圾桶，也许在戏里说一句台词，只是实习。他们有一个项目，你可以试镜并成为非工会团体的一部分。在我那里的第一个夏天之后，我还在上大学。第二年我试镜了，我成为了那个团体的一部分。一堆经纪人去那里，你是对的？
Basically.
Yeah.
Yeah, and he had tipped me off to a place called the Williamstown Theater Festival.
Sure. And I went there to sort of, you know, empty garbage cans and maybe say one line in a play and just intern.
And they had like a program where you could audition and be part of a non-equity group.
And after my first summer there, I was still in college.
The next year I auditioned and I got to be part of that group.
A bunch of agents go up there, you're right?
基本上是这样。是的，他向我推荐了一个叫威廉斯敦戏剧节的地方。当然。我去那里，你知道，就是倒倒垃圾，或许在戏里说上一句台词，做个实习生。他们有一个项目，你可以去试镜，成为非工会演员组的一员。我在那里度过第一个夏天时还在上大学。第二年我参加了试镜，并成功加入了那个小组。很多经纪人都会去那里，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
After my third year there, I got an agent.
Sean, did you ever do that?
I'd love to do Williamstown.
Did you ever do that?
I would love to, no, but I would love to.
But, you know, Charlie was going to ask you,
like, there's, when we were all young, all four of us
是啊，是啊。我在那儿待了三年后，找了个经纪人。肖恩，你做过吗？我真想去威廉斯敦。你做过吗？我很想去，不，但我很想去。但是，你知道，查理，我本来想问你，就是，当我们都还年轻的时候，我们四个
and other people like us that are actors,
there was a definite path to what you wanted, right?
You got your head shots,
and then you had your resume on the back,
and then you would submit them to agents,
and then agents was in,
but now it seems so different.
Do you have friends, like,
还有像我们这样的演员，对于想要的东西，有一条明确的路径，对吧？你准备好头像照，背面印上简历，然后提交给经纪人，经纪人就会介入，但现在看起来完全不同了。你有朋友，比如，
Does your sister have friends?
I'm like, hey, Charlie, can you help my friend out?
They want to get into the biz and they need advice.
I mean, do you ever get people coming to you?
And what would that advice be now for kids rather than when we were growing up?
Weirdly, I don't get too much of that.
I don't know if I don't give off a vibe of that I'll help or I'm not sure why.
Do you feel, no, but let me rephrase that.
你妹妹有朋友吗？我就说，嘿，查理，你能帮帮我朋友吗？他们想进入这个行业，需要建议。我是说，有没有人来找你？对于现在的孩子来说，这些建议会是什么，而不是我们成长的时候？奇怪的是，我没怎么遇到过这种情况。我不知道是不是我没散发出那种我会帮忙的氛围，或者我不确定为什么。你觉得，不，让我换个说法。
Do you feel shitty about yourself that nobody wants acting tips from you?
or career advice
I had that Sean you know when I was a kid
this true story when I was living in New York
and I was my I didn't know anybody in New York
and somehow my mom knew
through somebody from like Winnipeg
knew the actor Len Carey. Do you know that guy
你有没有因为没人找你讨教表演技巧或职业建议而感到难过？肖恩，你知道吗，我小时候，这是个真实的故事，当时我住在纽约，我不认识任何人，不知怎么的，我妈妈通过温尼伯的一个熟人认识了演员莱恩·卡里奥。你认识那个人吗？
sure Len Cario
and so somehow she's like you should call him
and I was like okay so I called them
poor guy because now I sort of
30 years later I get that flip,
which is like, he's like,
hey, what can I do for you?
I'm like, well, I'm just in New York
当然，莱恩·卡里奥，不知怎么的，她说你应该给他打个电话，我就说好吧，所以我给他打了电话，可怜的家伙，因为现在，大约30年后，我明白了那种感觉，就像，他说，嘿，我能为你做什么？我说，嗯，我刚到纽约，
and I'm going to theater school.
I'm like, okay.
I'm ready to be successful.
Yeah, and like I get now that position.
I even felt it at the time where he's like,
I don't know what you want me to do for you, buddy,
but, you know, I'm worried about my own day to day over here.
Right, right.
我在上戏剧学校。我说，好吧。我准备好成功了。是啊，我现在理解那种处境了。我当时甚至感觉到了，他就像是，伙计，我不知道你想让我为你做什么，但我还在担心我自己的日常生计呢。对，对。
And so you do get those calls sometimes from friends of friends,
and they go, hey, our kid is 18,
and he's moving to New York,
and can you call him and give him some advice?
And there's really nothing you can say to anybody.
I actually like it.
I actually don't mind it.
Yeah, it's all about timing, but yeah, I actually, actually like...
所以你有时确实会接到朋友的朋友打来的电话，他们说，嘿，我们的孩子18岁了，要搬到纽约去，你能给他打个电话给点建议吗？其实你对谁也说不出什么。我其实挺喜欢的。我其实不介意。是啊，这全看时机，但是的，我其实，其实喜欢……
What do you tell people, you know,
because getting an agent, like you do have to get into kind of a showcase situation.
It's just really tough for everybody.
I think you have to create your own path.
You know, gone are the days of relying and waiting on phone calls and agents and all that to do it for you.
You have to pick up a camera.
You have to write the thing, direct the thing, act the thing, put it on YouTube,
all that kind of stuff and Instagram.
你告诉人们什么呢，你知道，因为找经纪人，你确实得进入那种展示的场合。这对每个人来说都真的很难。我认为你必须开辟自己的道路。你知道，依靠等待电话、经纪人等等来为你做这些事的日子已经一去不复返了。你必须拿起摄像机。你必须写剧本、导演、表演，把它放到YouTube上，还有Instagram之类的东西。
And that's how,
because every Instagram star wants to be an actor
and every actor wants to be, like, have the most followers.
Well, Charlie, you guys were kind of like the first people
to really do that in a way that has been not just successful,
but also had longevity.
You guys created your own stuff.
That was not the norm before you guys did that.
这就是原因，因为每个Instagram明星都想成为演员，每个演员都想拥有最多的粉丝。嗯，查理，你们算是第一批真正做到这一点的人，不仅成功了，而且还保持了长久。你们创造了自己的东西。在你们做这件事之前，这并不是常态。
No, that's true, yeah.
Although, you know, in some ways, doesn't everybody do that?
Like, somebody...
I guess the Lonely Island guys did that, too.
Yeah, like...
Well, but they were already part of an infrastructure there at Saturday Night Live.
No, no, no, no, before.
Those guys made videos and stuff.
不，那是真的，是的。虽然，你知道，在某些方面，难道不是每个人都这样做吗？比如，有人……我想孤独岛乐队（The Lonely Island）的人也那样做了。是啊，就像……嗯，但他们已经是周六夜现场（Saturday Night Live）基础设施的一部分了。不，不，不，不，在那之前。那些家伙制作了视频之类的东西。
When they did, they did.
Andy Samir.
Andy and Akiva and Yoram did.
Oh, really?
Yeah, they made some videos on Lonely Island.
Then they made a pilot called Awesome Town that Phil and Chris, Phil Lord and Chris Miller produced.
Have you ever seen that?
It's really, it's really rad.
当他们做的时候，他们确实做了。安迪、萨米尔。安迪、阿基瓦和约拉姆做了。哦，真的吗？是的，他们在孤独岛上制作了一些视频。然后他们制作了一个名为《Awesome Town》的试播集，由菲尔和克里斯，菲尔·洛德和克里斯·米勒制作。你见过吗？真的很棒。
But they did the same thing, which was, but again, that was around the same time that Sunny started.
It was back in that.
What was unique about what we did is we did it for television.
Right.
You know, like you, there was a lot of that in independent film.
If you're the Cohen brothers, you know, you raise money, you do Blood Simple,
and then you go do Raising Arizona, whatever it is.
And I guess we just took that model to television.
但他们做了同样的事情，不过话说回来，那大约和《费城永远阳光灿烂》开始的时间差不多。是在那个时候。我们所做的事情的独特之处在于我们是为电视做的。对。你知道，就像你一样，独立电影里有很多这种情况。如果你是科恩兄弟，你知道，你筹集资金，拍了《血迷宫》，然后去拍《抚养亚利桑那》，不管是什么。我想我们只是把那个模式带到了电视上。
And we said, well, we'll, you know, we'll do the first one real cheap and down dirty.
And then hopefully someone gives us money to do this more legitimately.
But going back to your question before, I often do promote Williamstown,
which for me was like a showcase situation.
or if you're really serious about acting,
go to grad school, which I'd wish I'd done.
Because that place was not only boot camp for acting,
it was boot camp for you better show up and shine.
我们说，好吧，我们会，你知道，我们会把第一部拍得很便宜，很粗糙。然后希望有人给我们钱让我们更正规地做这件事。但回到你之前的问题，我经常推荐威廉斯敦，对我来说，那就像一个展示的场合。或者如果你真的认真对待表演，去读研究生，我真希望我当时读了。因为那个地方不仅是表演的训练营，也是让你必须表现并闪耀的训练营。
Because in that group, in that non-equity group,
it was myself and Catherine Hahn and Sterling Brown.
Wow.
And, I mean, the competition was so fierce.
And Jimmy Simpson, and these people were going to outshine you.
They weren't trying to outshine you,
but they were going to do their work.
and they were going to be, you know,
因为在那个小组里，那个非工会小组，有我和凯瑟琳·哈恩，还有斯特林·布朗。哇。而且，竞争非常激烈。还有吉米·辛普森，这些人会盖过你的风头。他们不是故意要盖过你，但他们会做好他们的工作。他们会，你知道，
they were going to come to rehearsal, not set,
and just blow it out of the water.
So you had to learn how to,
I feel like my first summer there,
I did well in some plays,
and I thought the next year I thought everyone would be like,
well, he's the man, let's give him everything,
and it wasn't that way, you know,
他们会来排练，而不是片场，然后表现得非常出色。所以你必须学会如何，我觉得我在那里的第一个夏天，我在一些戏里表现得不错，我以为第二年每个人都会觉得，嗯，他是个人物，让我们给他一切，但事实并非如此，你知道，
it was a rude awakening of like,
well, you did that, what are you going to do now?
So that was such a good boot camp in terms of, like,
do your work, work hard,
make sure you make sure you're not wasting anybody's time.
It's funny you say that I remember having one of my acting teachers years ago
he was saying like, look, all the process you do, all the work you do, whatever,
when you show up on said, they don't give a shit.
那是一个残酷的觉醒，就像，嗯，你做到了那个，现在你要做什么？所以那是一个很好的训练营，关于，做好你的工作，努力工作，确保你没有浪费任何人的时间。有趣的是你这么说，我记得多年前我的一位表演老师说过，看，你做的所有过程，你做的所有工作，无论什么，当你出现在片场时，他们根本不在乎。
You've got to deliver in the moment and that's it.
And that was the only sort of piece of advice that I've ever given young people,
which is just like you've got to be on top of your shit.
You've got to know your shit like you said.
You've got to be ready to deliver in the moment because that's what matters.
Yeah, and it's a bit exhausting, right?
You do, like you put all this work.
into this years go by you you develop whatever fame success and you kind of think okay well now i can
你必须在当下交付成果，就是这样。这是我给年轻人唯一的建议，就是你必须掌控好你的事情。你必须像你说的那样了解你的事情。你必须准备好在当下交付成果，因为那才是最重要的。是啊，这有点让人筋疲力尽，对吧？你确实，你投入了所有的工作。几年过去了，你发展了某种名气和成功，你有点认为，好吧，现在我可以
coast but you know the phone doesn't really ring maybe it does for decaprio but for nobody else like
you have to like you got to put something together and you have to and then when you when you are in it
you can't stink right you got to yeah you got to shine um your son is he too young to know that he
wants to do what dad does or yeah where mom does too both you guys are actors yeah yeah mary elizabeth has
this great part in Paul Thomas Anderson's film right now.
Oh, she's great at it.
That movie's amazing.
Yeah, that guy.
轻松一下了，但你知道，电话并没有真正响起来，也许迪卡普里奥会响，但其他人不会，你必须，你得把一些东西拼凑起来，然后当你身处其中时，你不能演砸了，对吧，你必须，你必须闪耀。嗯，你的儿子，他太小了，不知道他想做他爸爸做的事吗？或者，是的，妈妈也做，你们俩都是演员。是啊，是啊，玛丽·伊丽莎白现在在保罗·托马斯·安德森的电影里有一个很棒的角色。哦，她演得太棒了。那部电影太神奇了。是啊，那家伙。
Paul Thomas Anderson?
Yeah, talk about a guy.
I think he's going to work out for him, I think.
He's going to make it.
He's a great debut.
He has going to make it.
Paul Thomas Anderson is the greatest director of all time.
And go.
保罗·托马斯·安德森？是啊，说起那个人。我想他会成功的，我想。他会成功的。他是一个伟大的首秀。他会成功的。保罗·托马斯·安德森是有史以来最伟大的导演。开始吧。
And ignite.
How about he's my favorite, for sure?
I know, me too.
He's the greatest.
I got to go see a screening of that movie at his house,
which, you know,
he has these, maybe he doesn't want, but he has like these film projectors.
He's got like this barn that he's converted into like a screening room.
点燃吧。他绝对是我最喜欢的，怎么样？我知道，我也是。他是最伟大的。我有幸在他家看了一场那部电影的放映，你知道，他有这些，也许他不想，但他有这些电影放映机。他有一个谷仓，被改造成了放映室。
And for Tracy, the name of the movie is.
Liquorice pizza.
Liquorce pizza.
Yeah.
Which is the name of a record store that was all over the valley when I was growing up.
Right.
It's, uh, anyway.
So he's got this cool.
对于特雷西，电影的名字是。《甘草披萨》（Licorice Pizza）。《甘草披萨》。是啊。这是我成长过程中山谷里到处都是的一家唱片店的名字。对。总之，所以他有这个很酷的。
That's why you're crying.
So, so, and your wife, Emmy, Mary Elizabeth Ellis, whom I know, she and I did a pilot together.
Years ago, as you know.
Yes, yes.
And she's a tremendously talented actor,
and she's in Paul Thomas Anderson's movie Liquorice Pizza.
So you went to a screening at his screening.
At his house.
这就是你哭的原因。所以，所以，还有你的妻子，艾米，玛丽·伊丽莎白·埃利斯，我认识她，她和我一起拍过一个试播集。多年前，如你所知。是的，是的。她是一位非常有才华的演员，她在保罗·托马斯·安德森的电影《甘草披萨》里。所以你去参加了他的放映。在他家。
Screening burn.
Yeah, just to kind of...
And then to get to hang out with Maya Rudolph.
So that was a...
Who's our pal?
I just didn't want to blow it for my wife.
I'm like, just keep cool, man, and don't get drunk and don't act dumb.
Did you stand up with a bunch of notes at the end of it?
放映谷仓。是啊，只是为了……然后还能和玛雅·鲁道夫待在一起。所以那是一个……谁是我们的朋友？我只是不想为我妻子搞砸了。我心想，保持冷静，伙计，别喝醉，别表现得像个傻瓜。最后你有没有站起来提一堆意见？
I had a couple notes, but he wasn't listening, you know?
That's the problem.
these artists.
Yeah, we were locked.
Pop Charlie Day in for a couple scenes.
That's really going to make this movie pop.
We'll be right back.
All right, back to the show.
我有几个意见，但他没听，你知道吗？这就是问题所在。这些艺术家。是啊，我们被锁住了。让查理·戴在几个场景里客串一下。那真的会让这部电影火起来。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目。
Now, listen, Charlie, for your new podcast,
which I think it's becoming really popular, isn't it?
Do you guys have guests on,
or is it just you three chatting?
Right now, it's just us chatting.
I mean, that kind of caught us off guard, you know.
This was my gripe with McElhenney.
About two years ago, I was like,
现在，听着，查理，对于你的新播客，我觉得它正变得非常受欢迎，不是吗？你们有嘉宾吗，还是只有你们三个在聊天？目前，只是我们自己在聊天。我是说，这让我们措手不及，你知道。这是我对麦克尔亨尼的抱怨。大约两年前，我说，
we should do a sunny podcast.
We should just talk about the show,
the fans will probably want to hear that.
And he's like, ah, everybody's doing podcasts, you know, like, you know, we're too late.
Then this year he shows up, he goes, you know what we should do?
A sunny podcast.
Oh, boy.
I'm like, this motherfucker.
我们应该做一个《阳光灿烂》的播客。我们应该只谈论这部剧，粉丝们可能想听听。他说，啊，每个人都在做播客，你知道，我们太晚了。然后今年他出现了，他说，你知道我们应该做什么吗？一个《阳光灿烂》的播客。哦，天哪。我说，这个混蛋。
I'm like, yeah, I know this guy.
But here's the difference.
And here's why I've benefited so greatly from a partnership with Rob.
When I said it, it was just gobbledygook talk.
And when he said it, he already had the mics and the producer lined up and ready to go.
He's an action.
He's an action guy.
我说，是啊，我认识这家伙。但区别在于。这就是为什么我从与罗布的合作中受益匪浅的原因。当我说的时候，那只是胡言乱语。而当他说的时候，他已经准备好了麦克风和制片人，随时可以开始。他是一个行动派。他是一个行动派。他是一个行动派。
So it's been good for me to.
unite with an action guy.
Being on that side of it, do you,
and we all know this as actors,
promoting and marketing and all that stuff,
having to do talk shows and whatever podcast
or whatever the thing is,
do you have a preference of being a guest or a host?
所以与一个行动派联合对我来说很好。作为演员，身处那一面，你，我们都知道这一点，推广、营销等等，不得不做脱口秀和任何播客或任何事情，你更喜欢做嘉宾还是主持人？
Well, I guess we're not really hosting anyone,
so I don't know for hosting yet.
Yeah, I mean, you're kind of hosting a podcast, but yeah.
We're really just kind of shooting the shit.
Okay.
People seem to want to listen to it.
But you're, I think that one of the things,
We're all talking about the same thing.
嗯，我想我们并没有真正主持任何人，所以我不知道我们是否在主持。是啊，我是说，你有点在主持一个播客，但是的。我们真的只是在闲聊。好吧。人们似乎想听。但你，我认为其中一件事，我们都在谈论同一件事。
We obviously have, there are a lot of similarities,
which is you talk about we create our own weather,
we do our own thing,
and we do a lot of different things.
You're doing a podcast, you do your show,
you've got this new movie on Amazon,
that was a sexy segue.
That was a good segue, yeah.
我们显然有，有很多相似之处，那就是你谈论我们创造自己的天气，我们做自己的事情，我们做很多不同的事情。你在做播客，你在做你的节目，你在亚马逊上有这部新电影，那是一个性感的过渡。那是一个很好的过渡，是的。
So I did a rom-com, finally.
So you did a rom-com, yeah.
Saw me as ROM.
So talk a little bit about,
because I want to get into,
you do do a lot of different stuff
and you've got a lot of different gears.
which is commendable, and you're, you know, you're a talented guy.
所以我拍了一部浪漫喜剧，终于。所以你拍了一部浪漫喜剧，是啊。把我当成浪漫喜剧演员。所以谈谈吧，因为我想深入了解，你确实做了很多不同的事情，你有很多不同的档次。这是值得称赞的，而且你，你知道，你是一个有才华的人。
So you go and you do a rom-com.
What was the, were you just like, yeah, fuck it, I could do a rom-com.
I was always dying to do a rom-com because I actually really enjoy them.
And I sort of wanted to have my, you know, Tom Hanks moment or Billy Crystal or whatever.
Was there a sex scene?
No, there's, there's, you know.
Is there a kiss?
Hey, cool it.
所以你去拍了一部浪漫喜剧。当时是，你只是觉得，去他的，我可以拍一部浪漫喜剧吗？我一直渴望拍一部浪漫喜剧，因为我真的很喜欢它们。我有点想拥有我的，你知道，汤姆·汉克斯时刻或比利·克里斯托时刻之类的。有性爱场景吗？不，有，有，你知道。有吻戏吗？嘿，冷静点。
Hey, take it easy, man.
What are you imagining? Jason, what are you imagining?
Talk to what you're imagining.
Well, because some people can go, they're whole.
whole careers or a large portion of it without ever doing a sex scene.
And then all of a sudden, the day shows up and it's like, oh, my God, I've been in this business
30 years.
And I've never had to like fake lovemaking.
嘿，放轻松，伙计。你在想象什么？杰森，你在想象什么？说说你在想象什么。嗯，因为有些人可以，他们整个职业生涯或很大一部分时间里从来没有拍过性爱场景。然后突然有一天，日子到了，就像，哦，天哪，我入行30年了。我从来没有不得不假装做爱。
Did you have to do that?
No, that's a good question.
Have you ever had to do that?
Yeah, I have a, I have a very graphic one on It's Always Sunny where we did a ski episode
and we were making sort of fun of like 80s ski movies and over the top sex scenes.
So, you know, I would like that go.
It was fine, you know.
You don't have to ask him in a whisper, Will.
你不得不那样做吗？不，这是个好问题。你曾经不得不那样做吗？是啊，我在《费城永远阳光灿烂》里有一个非常露骨的场景，我们拍了一集滑雪，我们有点在嘲笑80年代的滑雪电影和夸张的性爱场景。所以，你知道，我愿意那样做。没关系，你知道。你不需要低声问他，威尔。
You don't just say, walk us through it.
I mean, you know, it's always the case of me with the sex things.
I'm always, I always feel bad for the other person.
You know, I'm like, hey, look, I'm sorry, it's just me and this, you know, I'm pasty.
Sean, you had to do one?
Yeah, there was this cult show, which is fantastic, called Campus Ladies,
with Carrie Aesley and Kristen Susson and Will Forte was on it,
and a bunch of funny people were on it.
你不需要说，带我们过一遍。我是说，你知道，对我来说，性爱场景总是这样。我总是，我总是为另一个人感到难过。你知道，我就像，嘿，看，我很抱歉，只是我和这个，你知道，我脸色苍白。肖恩，你不得不拍过一个吗？是啊，有一部邪典剧，非常棒，叫《校园女郎》（Campus Ladies），有凯莉·埃斯利和克里斯汀·萨森，威尔·福特也在里面，还有一堆有趣的人在里面。
Jonah Hill. That was Jonah Hill's first show.
And I played somebody who wasn't the brightest, who always wore a backpack.
How'd you get into that character?
Wow. So I just put a backpack on.
And then I had to wear no clothes except the backpack and have sex with, and literally have intercourse with Kristen Susson.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
How did that go?
乔纳·希尔。那是乔纳·希尔的第一部剧。我扮演了一个不太聪明的人，总是背着背包。你是怎么进入那个角色的？哇。所以我只是背上了一个背包。然后我不得不不穿衣服，只背着背包，和克里斯汀·萨森发生性关系，字面意义上的性交。哦。哦，好吧。那进展如何？
Jason?
Fine.
Oh, sorry, go ahead. Sean. Finish up.
How is it?
That was it?
Jason, what about your sex stuff?
I've got a loose connection. Can you guys hear me okay?
Yeah.
杰森？很好。哦，抱歉，请继续。肖恩。说完。怎么样？就是那样？杰森，你的性爱戏呢？我的连接有点松。你们能听清我说话吗？是啊。
Is that what you said, in the sex scene?
I'm not following.
My wire keeps coming out.
And can you hear me?
Yeah.
And is it in?
I guess that's the big.
Hey, Charlie.
那是你说的吗，在性爱场景里？我没跟上。我的线一直掉出来。你能听到我吗？是啊。而且它进去了吗？我想那是最大的。嘿，查理。
Wait, you didn't answer, Jason, if you've done a sex scene.
I have, and I don't like them.
They're not good.
It's just, you know, all the cliches are true.
You know, you have a, is a very, there's a very difficult line one has to ride,
which is, you know, if you're into it
and you're being passionate convincingly,
things start to move, guys.
等等，你还没回答，杰森，如果你拍过性爱场景的话。我拍过，我不喜欢它们。它们不好。只是，你知道，所有的陈词滥调都是真的。你知道，你有一个，有一个非常困难的界限需要把握，那就是，你知道，如果你沉浸其中，并且令人信服地充满激情，事情就开始移动了，伙计们。
And if they don't move,
there's that classic saying,
one of the actors said,
I apologize if I get aroused
and I apologize if I don't get aroused
or something like that.
It's like, it's a, it's a concern.
It's a concern.
如果它们不动，有一句经典名言，其中一位演员说，如果我勃起了我道歉，如果我没勃起我也道歉之类的。这就像，这是一个，这是一个担忧。这是一个担忧。
Well, Batman, we did this movie called Horrible Bosses.
It was a massive global hit will.
And, um...
Oh, you had a little sex scene with Aniston, right?
That was the first thing...
Yeah, that was the first thing we shot.
Oh, wow, boy.
And that was basically my second time meeting her.
嗯，蝙蝠侠，我们拍了一部叫《恶老板》（Horrible Bosses）的电影。那是一个巨大的全球热门，威尔。而且，嗯……哦，你和安妮斯顿有一场小小的性爱戏，对吧？那是第一件事……是啊，那是我们拍的第一件事。哦，哇，天哪。那基本上是我第二次见到她。
I met her at the, uh, at the read through.
It was like, okay, well, now take all your clothes off
and we'll take these provocative photos.
But I only found it humiliating, you know,
because I was like, oh, man, I should, like go to the gym or like...
Sure.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
I'm really pasty and doughy over here and, uh, you know.
我在读剧本的时候见到她。就像，好吧，现在脱掉你所有的衣服，我们要拍这些挑衅的照片。但我只觉得羞辱，你知道，因为我就像，哦，天哪，我应该，去健身房或者……当然。我就像，我很抱歉。我在这里脸色苍白，软绵绵的，而且，你知道。
You're probably not used to an image like this in your sexual scenarios.
I had to do a scene in Brother Solomon with Forte
where he comes to, where we make up at the end of the movie,
and I'm in the shower.
And I come out, so I've just got the little sock on
and then nothing else.
And then I got to turn in, he and I have to hug while I'm basically...
No, let's, for Tracy, let's explain what the sock is.
你可能不习惯在你的性场景中看到这样的形象。我在《所罗门兄弟》（Brother Solomon）里不得不和福特拍一场戏，他在电影结尾时我们和好了，我在淋浴。我出来，所以我只穿了那个小袜子，然后什么都没穿。然后我得转身，他和我都得拥抱，而我基本上……不，让我们，对于特雷西，解释一下袜子是什么。
Go ahead, well.
It's basically that.
Like, it's a sock that you put over, it's the thing you put over your junk.
All your meats and cheeses get covered.
Yeah.
It's like it's a little coin purse that's got a couple of pieces of fishing wire on both sides that go around you as a thong.
Okay.
继续，威尔。基本上就是那样。就像，这是一个你套在上面的袜子，这是你套在你的家伙上的东西。你所有的肉和奶酪都被盖住了。是啊。它就像一个小硬币包，两边有几根钓鱼线，像丁字裤一样绕着你。是啊。好吧。
But it's a nude.
It's a nude colored and it's made out of like panty hose and with fishing string on it.
So you can imagine it's just it's not comfortable.
It's not a good looking thing.
And it's difficult at times to fill out.
Will?
And it's well, that was not an issue.
It was more of an issue.
但它是裸色的，是用连裤袜做的，上面有钓鱼线。所以你可以想象，它只是，它不舒服。它不是一个好看的东西。而且有时很难填满。威尔？而且它，嗯，那不是问题。更多的问题是
that like it was kind of the, like you said, like,
I'm sorry if I get it aroused,
and I'm sorry if I don't.
And I just thought, boy, this could go either way with Forte.
I have no idea.
Which way did it go?
I don't want to say it, but I just, I love the guy.
Let me just say this, I love the guy.
就像你说的，就像，如果我勃起了我道歉，如果我没勃起我也道歉。我只是想，天哪，这和福特在一起可能会朝任何方向发展。我不知道。结果怎么样？我不想说，但我只是，我爱那个家伙。让我只说这个，我爱那个家伙。
And you can tell.
Well, you've said plenty.
So Charlie, when, so you're doing this romance and comedy,
you decide you want to do it.
What is the movie?
Well, the movie's called I Want You Back,
and it's with Jenny,
Slate and myself.
而且看得出来。嗯，你已经说得够多了。所以查理，当，所以你在做这个浪漫和喜剧，你决定你想做它。那部电影是什么？嗯，电影叫《我要回去了》（I Want You Back），是珍妮·斯莱特和我一起演的。
She's a talent.
She's pretty good.
Our producing buddy
John Ricard produced this movie.
Another mega talent.
Yeah, and we worked together
on horrible bosses and fist fight.
她很有才华。她很不错。她很不错。我们的制片伙伴约翰·里卡德制作了这部电影。另一个超级天才。是啊，我们在《恶老板》和《拳斗》（Fist Fight）上合作过。
And I was talking to John,
and I was saying, you know,
we should find something to do.
And he says,
he said, I got these two scripts
and you should look at them.
And he said, but one's a rom-com,
so you probably don't want to do that.
我当时在和约翰谈，我说，你知道，我们应该找点事情做。他说，他说，我有这两个剧本，你应该看看。他说，但一个是浪漫喜剧，所以你可能不想做那个。
I said, why would I not want to do that?
What a nasty, nasty thing to say.
Nasty thing to say.
And I loved it.
We put it together.
It's a really sweet and funny movie.
By the way, I did have to take my shirt off in it.
And I had this sort of conundrum where the character doesn't work out,
我说，我为什么不想做那个？多么刻薄，多么刻薄的话。刻薄的话。我很喜欢它。我们把它拼凑起来了。这是一部非常甜蜜和有趣的电影。顺便说一句，我确实不得不在里面脱掉衬衫。我遇到了这种难题，角色不锻炼，
and then he starts working out in the story.
And I thought, well, which body do I go with?
Do I go with the guy who looks like he's not been working out
or the guy that looks like he has been working out?
And I went with the guy who has not been working out.
Yeah, it was...
Did you look at the shooting schedule to sort of plan out
what kind of shape you'd be in?
然后他在故事里开始锻炼了。我想，嗯，我选哪个身体？我是选那个看起来没锻炼过的家伙，还是选那个看起来锻炼过的家伙？我选了那个没锻炼过的家伙。是啊，那是……你有没有看拍摄计划来规划一下你会是什么状态？
Because I do that.
I mean, for Tracy, these projects,
they take at least six weeks to shoot,
sometimes 12 or more.
And if you know you got a topless scene on,
as Will likes to call it,
you know, you want to make sure
that you're not having a whole lot of soy sauce
因为我这样做。我是说，对于特雷西，这些项目，它们至少需要六周拍摄，有时12周或更多。如果你知道你有一场上空戏，正如威尔喜欢称呼的那样，你知道，你想要确保你没有吃太多的酱油，
a few days out, you know?
No, I let that go.
I was like, now, that's not what the audience wants for me.
They don't want me to pop that shirt off
and have rippling abs.
They don't want it, they'll be disturbed if they see it.
There's nothing funny about a six-pack.
There's nothing funny about it.
提前几天，你知道吗？不，我放手了。我就像，不，那不是观众想要的。他们不想要我脱掉衬衫，露出波浪形的腹肌。他们不想要，如果他们看到它，他们会感到不安。六块腹肌没什么好笑的。没什么好笑的。
And this is a comedy.
So, Charlie, any recent vacays, as we call it in the biz?
Any vacays with the fam?
I went to Hawaii.
Okay.
I knew that.
I knew that because I saw that pick.
Oh, yeah, you sent us a shot of that beautiful.
这是一部喜剧。所以，查理，最近有什么假期吗，正如我们在行业里所说的？和家人有什么假期吗？我去了夏威夷。好吧。我知道。我知道，因为我看到了那张照片。哦，是啊，你发给我们一张那张美丽的。
You sent that pick in our little chain.
Oh, yeah, I did.
I did.
That's right.
So you went to Hawaii.
Did you go by yourself or did you bring your wife and child?
No, of course I brought my wife and child.
And I played a bunch of golf, and we hung out and relaxed and went to the beach.
你把那张照片发到了我们的小群里。哦，是啊，我发了。我发了。没错。所以你去了夏威夷。你是自己去的，还是带了妻子和孩子？不，我当然带了妻子和孩子。我打了很多高尔夫球，我们待在一起放松，去了海滩。
And I reset.
It was good.
I was coming right off a bunch of things,
and it was nice to take a break.
Charlie, 2022, what are you most excited about?
Oh, man.
I don't know.
I'm always pretty just excited to be doing this.
我重置了。很好。我刚从一堆事情中解脱出来，休息一下很好。查理，2022年，你最期待什么？哦，天哪。我不知道。我总是很兴奋能做这件事。
I mean, I don't know.
I'm still grateful to be doing it.
Yeah.
I've been polishing up a movie for a good four years
that I directed that Bateman was kind enough to be in.
Yeah, when do we get to see that, Charlie?
Any minute.
I'm right around the corner.
我是说，我不知道。我仍然很感激能做这件事。是啊。我一直在润色一部我导演的电影，整整四年了，蝙蝠侠很客气地参与了。是啊，我们什么时候能看到那个，查理？随时。我就在拐角处。
But I was going to sell it.
I was in the process of selling it to a studio.
And I was having some conversations
with a very talented man, Mr. Guillermo del Toro.
And I had a change of heart,
and I took the movie, and I reshot about 20% of it.
Am I still in it?
You're still in it.
但我本来打算卖掉它。我正在把它卖给一家制片厂。我正在和一位非常有才华的人，吉列尔莫·德尔·托罗先生进行一些对话。我改变了主意，我拿回了电影，重拍了大约20%。我还在里面吗？你还在里面。
You made the cut.
That's been a maddening, long experience,
but I'm really happy with the movie.
So hopefully I'll get it out to the world this year.
I'm excited about that.
I'm excited about this rom-com.
I'm excited about maybe getting some golf in with the boys here, you know?
That's good.
你入选了。那是一次令人抓狂的、漫长的经历，但我对这部电影真的很满意。所以希望我今年能把它推向世界。我很期待那个。我很期待这部浪漫喜剧。我很期待也许能和这里的伙计们打打高尔夫球，你知道吗？那很好。
And Horrible Bosses 3, I think we can announce.
Well, now, why didn't we do it, you know?
Well, because...
No one wanted it.
Yeah, because Horrible Buses 2 just basically, you know, cratered.
Did it? Did it shit the bed?
Did it?
By today's standards, it's a huge hit.
还有《恶老板3》，我想我们可以宣布了。嗯，现在，我们为什么没做呢，你知道？嗯，因为……没人想要它。是啊，因为《恶老板2》基本上，你知道，崩溃了。是吗？它搞砸了吗？是吗？以今天的标准来看，它是一个巨大的热门。
Oh, that's true, yeah.
It didn't do as well as the first...
Oh, you mean by pandemic standards?
Yeah, that's right.
By the standards of everybody's staying home and not going to...
going into theaters.
Well, I would like the third one
because I really, really like to collect those sets.
哦，那是真的，是啊。它没有第一部做得那么好……哦，你是说按大流行标准？是啊，没错。按每个人都待在家里不去……不去电影院的标准。嗯，我想要第三部，因为我真的，真的很喜欢收集那些系列。
Yeah, oh, yeah.
Things do happen in three.
Maybe we just make it for a price, you know.
But it did turn out people just didn't give shit
about a second one,
so they're really not going to want a third.
It's not really a story that needed a sequel.
Hear me out.
是啊，哦，是啊。事情确实事不过三。也许我们只是按价格制作它，你知道。但事实证明，人们根本不在乎第二部，所以他们真的不会想要第三部。这不是一个真正需要续集的故事。听我说。
Shornbable Boss is three, but there are two new, Sean, right?
Two new guys who, look, they're kind of...
They just go...
Oh.
They're happening.
My boss is terrible.
My boss is bad.
too. Are you a boss or you're
《恶老板3》，但有两个新人，肖恩，对吧？两个新人，看，他们有点……他们只是……哦。他们正在发生。我的老板很糟糕。我的老板也很糟糕。你是老板还是你是
an employee? Exactly.
But the catchphrase is, my boss is
bad three. Yeah.
Same here. I get it,
Sean. I get it.
So, Charlie, listen, you're
just, you're such a talent.
You're such a good guy. You're a theater.
员工？没错。但口号是，我的老板很糟糕3。是啊。我也是。我明白了，肖恩。我明白了。所以，查理，听着，你真是个天才。你真是个好人。你是个戏剧。
You're a theater major.
You're a musician, golfer.
Great marriage. Charming little kid.
Your new movie, I want you back.
Your rom-com is out.
I can't wait to see it. And it's on Amazon
now. It's really good. I actually love this movie a lot.
Charlie, I love you. Charlie, thank you for being here.
你是戏剧专业的。你是音乐家，高尔夫球手。婚姻美满。可爱的孩子。你的新电影，《我要回去了》。你的浪漫喜剧出来了。我迫不及待想看它。而且它现在在亚马逊上。它真的很好。我其实非常喜欢这部电影。查理，我爱你。查理，谢谢你来到这里。
We see you on the golf course probably in the next few days.
Well, you're teeing off in about, what, 10 minutes?
Yeah, this is already six minutes into my heart out. Yeah, he's got a hard out.
That shows how much he loves you. He never does this if he's got a heart out for golf.
I appreciate the six minutes over. That's good. And you know how persnickety, Jason is about everything.
My range time. I need my range time.
Yeah.
Well, we can come back.
我们可能在接下来的几天里在高尔夫球场见到你。嗯，你大约10分钟后开球？是啊，这已经占用了我6分钟了。是啊，他有一个硬性截止时间。这显示了他有多爱你。如果他有高尔夫的硬性截止时间，他从不这样做。我很感激这多出来的6分钟。那很好。而且你知道杰森对每件事有多挑剔。我的练习场时间。我需要我的练习场时间。是啊。嗯，我们可以回来。
I can come back.
We'll finish this off.
And next time you're on the podcast,
we'll talk about the time when we were coming down 18
and the guy hadn't charged Jason's Tesla.
I had a two-hour drive ahead of me.
It didn't either well.
You made him give him his...
我可以回来。我们会完成这个。下次你上播客时，我们会谈谈我们下到18洞时，那个人没给杰森的特斯拉充电的那次。我前面还有两个小时的车程。它也没做好。你让他把他的……
My 20 back.
Yeah, 20 back, yeah, yeah.
I gave him 20 just because I felt bad.
He got yelled at so much.
Jason, you don't know this,
but Charlie and I both tipped the guy
after you took the tip back.
Are you kidding me?
我的20块钱还给我。是啊，20块钱还回来，是啊，是啊。我给了他20块，只是因为我感到难过。他被骂得太惨了。杰森，你不知道这一点，但在你把小费拿回去后，查理和我俩都给了那个人小费。你在开玩笑吗？
No.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, we felt bad.
Well, we didn't want to write a story like fucking jigs.
I mean, you were his hero.
He fucked me good.
At least $20.
I should have taken more out of his pocket.
不。是啊，是啊，是啊。嗯，我们感到难过。嗯，我们不想写一个像该死的小费的故事。我是说，你是他的英雄。他把我搞砸了。至少20美元。我应该从他口袋里拿走更多。
Son of a bitch.
I will say, to your credit, you did preemptively tip the guy and say,
hey, do you mind taking care of this?
He said, great.
And then he didn't do it.
Right.
So it's like, well, I'm going to pay you for the valet parking.
But the extra juice for doing me a solid, which you didn't do.
狗娘养的。我得说，归功于你，你确实预先给了那个人小费，并说，嘿，你介意处理一下这个吗？他说，太棒了。然后他没做。对。所以就像，嗯，我会为你付代客泊车的钱。但为了帮我一个忙而给的额外报酬，你没做。
Yeah.
That then means that you no longer need the money for that.
Let me ask you.
this, if you had shot like even par
that day, like your best round ever.
Do you think you wouldn't have cared?
Do you think you would have been? I would have given him a ride
wherever he wanted to go and all the money in my pocket.
是啊。那意味着你不再需要那笔钱了。让我问你这个，如果你那天打出了标准杆，就像你最好的成绩一样。你觉得你会在乎吗？你觉得你会吗？我会载他去任何他想去的地方，并把口袋里所有的钱都给他。
And that is Jason Babeman.
Guys, we'll be right back with an all new episode of Smartless.
He loves his golf.
Charlie,
enjoy the rest of your day.
Great to see your faces, fellas.
Sean, let's hang out some time.
那就是杰森·贝特曼。伙计们，我们马上回来，带来全新的《Smartless》。他爱他的高尔夫。他爱他的高尔夫。查理，享受你剩下的时光。很高兴见到你们的脸，伙计们。肖恩，找时间一起玩吧。
I'm right here just for you.
Not worth it, Charlie.
No?
No. It's got to be better.
Bring the slide whistle.
Next two weeks, Texas, let's get out.
Okay.
I'm busy, but, you know, we'll see.
我就在这里，只为你。不值得，查理。不？不。必须更好。带上滑音哨。接下来的两周，德克萨斯，让我们出去吧。好吧。我很忙，但是，你知道，我们会看到的。
Yeah.
Okay.
All right, all right, all right.
He's about to slam a laptop.
He's going to do the good out.
You know, why?
Because, yeah, I'll tell you why I was going to do it,
because Sean Penn did it.
是啊。好吧。好了，好了，好了。他快要摔笔记本电脑了。他要做出那个好的退场。你知道，为什么？因为，是啊，我告诉你我为什么要做它，因为肖恩·潘做了。
And then I remember, I was listening to that,
I was like, wow, Sean Penn did it.
That's the way to do it.
I think I've done it ever since then.
I was like, well, Sean Penn just slams it down.
Yeah.
That's how you do it.
So I'm going to slam it down.
然后我记得，我在听那个，我就想，哇，肖恩·潘做了。那是做它的方式。我想从那以后我就一直这样做。我就想，嗯，肖恩·潘只是把它摔下来。是啊。这就是你做的方式。所以我把它摔下来。
Bye.
Oh, look, he really did it.
that Charlie Day is
he's a
always a breath of fresh air
isn't it every time you see him
you feel better
再见。再见。哦，看，他真的做了。那个查理·戴，他总是一股清新的空气，不是吗？每次你见到他，你都会感觉更好。
He's like we could change his middle name to sunny
Right so just Charlie's sunny day
Yeah always a sunny day
And Charlie
So Sean you don't know Charlie
You've never met him personally
I never met him I did that one voice over
Monsters University with him
他就像我们可以把他的中间名改成阳光（Sunny），对吧？所以只是查理·阳光·戴。是啊，总是阳光灿烂的一天。还有查理。所以肖恩，你不认识查理。你从来没亲自见过他。我从来没见过他。我和他一起做了那个配音，《怪兽大学》。
But of course you know as you know
When you do animated films
You don't really see the other actor
Because you're doing it a lot
What?
Yeah
So I never really met him
before. But I'm a huge fan.
但当然，如你所知，当你制作动画电影时，你并没有真正看到其他演员，因为你做了很多。什么？是啊。所以我从来没真正见过他。但我是一个超级粉丝。
And I don't know if you've seen Monsters University,
but he steals the movie.
He's hilarious. Yeah, of course. First of all, if you've got,
if you're a fan of comedy or you're a fan of animation
or you've got kids, you've seen Monsters University,
it's a great movie, and he is great in it. And you are,
but he is, but, no, it's a great movie.
And he is such a, I met him the first time was
我不知道你有没有看过《怪兽大学》，但他抢尽了风头。他太搞笑了。是啊，当然。首先，如果你是喜剧迷，或者你是动画迷，或者你有孩子，你一定看过《怪兽大学》，那是一部很棒的电影，他在里面很棒。而且你是，但他，但，不，那是一部很棒的电影。而且他是一个如此，我第一次见到他是
through his wife, through Emmy, Mary Elizabeth Ellis,
who's such a talent and so cool.
And he's a super nice guy, super real.
And he joked about being down to earth.
He legitimately is.
And then he's incredibly talented.
Yeah, I love him.
And prolific writer and just everything.
通过他的妻子，通过艾米，玛丽·伊丽莎白·埃利斯，她非常有才华，非常酷。他是一个超级好的人，超级真实。他开玩笑说自己脚踏实地。他确实是。而且他非常有才华。是啊，我爱他。多产的作家，简直是一切。
And he's so funny.
He's so naturally funny.
You guys got that.
You guys both have very unique voices.
Yes.
Yeah, he's got a very unique voice.
I don't know if I would consider myself too, but he does.
Wait, nobody ever bites my, for my theater stories.
而且他太搞笑了。他天生就很有趣。你们俩都有。你们俩都有非常独特的声音。是的。是啊，他有一个非常独特的声音。我不知道我是否会认为自己也是，但他确实有。等等，从来没有人买我的，我的戏剧故事。
Huh, number one.
So what we save it for a podcast no one wants to listen to?
Okay.
What's funny is that you don't take from that, like, maybe I should stop asking.
I'm telling you, your takeaway is nobody bites on it.
No, I'm telling you, somebody's going to come with a really funny theater story.
I think they're always so funny.
I like that usually your question about funny theater stories ends up with you telling a funny theater story.
嗯，第一。所以我们把它留给没人想听的播客？好吧。有趣的是，你没有从中得到，就像，也许我应该停止询问。我告诉你，你的收获是没人买账。不，我告诉你，会有人带着一个非常有趣的戏剧故事来。我觉得它们总是那么有趣。我喜欢你关于有趣戏剧故事的问题通常以你讲一个有趣的戏剧故事结束。
I know.
It's just a self-set-up.
Jason, you missed Sean the other day.
Robert and I kept pimping him out
to tell funny stories for everybody at dinner.
Funny theater stories.
So he kept, funny theater stories.
And he kept getting up and telling these hilarious,
我知道。这只是一个自我设置。杰森，你那天错过了肖恩。罗伯特和我一直在怂恿他给晚餐时的每个人讲有趣的故事。有趣的戏剧故事。所以他一直，有趣的戏剧故事。他一直站起来讲这些搞笑的，
they were legitimately hilarious.
And he got so worked up, he had to go to the hospital.
I did.
That's a true story.
So all of a sudden, Jen comes here,
she goes, Sean just went to the hospital.
I'm like, what?
You know, next time I bring up a theater story,
它们确实非常搞笑。他太激动了，不得不去医院。我去了。这是个真实的故事。所以突然间，詹来了，她说，肖恩刚去医院了。我就想，什么？你知道，下次我提起戏剧故事时，
maybe someone will bite,
bite, bite.
Bite.
Oh, bye.
Yes, got it.
Got it.
Not that works, that qualifies.
Love you guys.
也许有人会买账，买账，买账。买账。哦，再见。是的，明白了。明白了。那不算，那有资格。爱你们，伙计们。
Bye.
Love you, bye.
Smartless.
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry.
再见。爱你们，再见。《Smartless》。《Smartless》是100%有机的，由罗布·阿姆贾夫、贝内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作。《Smartless》。